he's the godfather of crime for two
decades
wiley has been an influential figure in
british culture
throughout his life he says he's been
stabbed more than 20 times
and has survived in a music industry
where he's regarded as an enigmatic
figure
that is until he posted a series of
anti-semitic comments on social media
he's been heavily criticized for
insulting jewish people
and comparing them to the klu klax clan
it's these remarks which have prompted
condemnation from all political parties
including the home secretary
i'm not racist you know i'm a
businessman so if you're not racist then
why did you make the following
anti-semitic comment you i'm going to
quote
yeah yeah yeah yeah you put out you said
jewish community
you're too touchy anyway israel is not
yours hold that
do i see why that could be uh as racism
should i read it again
no no no no it again if i read what
anti-some
anti-social termitism is and it says the
jewish community
is powerful within business that's
racist i think that's silly
i don't care what nobody says i want to
apologize for generalizing
number one and i want to apologize for
comments
that were looked at as anti-semitic it's
the first time wiley is speaking
following a dispute with his former
music manager john wolfe who is jewish
in my interview with rapper he repeated
similar comments to those posted on his
twitter
much of which is too inflammatory to
broadcast and despite saying he regrets
the generalizations he made about jewish
people
minutes later he also said this the
music industry
batch of people i'm talking about
they're the ones who get to benefit
from it that's what that's what this is
all about it's systemic racism from
their side
what do you think the system and that
man
and a community of jewish
liars and thingy have made me feel that
way
yes they have they've made me feel that
way not anti-semitic they've made me
feel
angry and upset because they are showing
me the systemic racism
and privilege that they're allowed to
use on us his remarks
are self-defeating and even though he
denies being a racist
wiley is still struggling to understand
why his comments have now led to a
police investigation
there are people who believe that your
tweets are vile and offensive
what do you say to those fans who may
take your word
and then go on to incite hatred or
commit violence acts against you
if you've never seen me commit a violent
act towards jewish people
or jewish people what do you want to say
to those fans who may misinterpret what
you've said
well what do you mean what i want to say
to them fans when they watch this
they'll realize
what is going on wouldn't they but what
do you want to say you know what do i
want to say to someone who is part of
that community
what do they want to say to someone
who's part of mine to your fans
you're no fans you've got fans are
fickle don't get don't don't wind me up
i'm 41 years old it's not like i got all
big bag of fans allow it i'm not dave
but you've got followers
no don't try it i'm not dave and that
i'm not current
like you know what i'm saying i'm 41 i'm
at the end of my career rather than the
beginning
the offence and outrage of the rapper's
remarks has left a jewish community
demanding action
the alarm and offense he's caused is
unimaginable
and he's clearly not sorry whatsoever
this is a man also with 500 000 twitter
followers
he needs to be charged with incitement
to racial hatred he needs to face
the full force of the law seen here with
prince william
in 2018 wylie was awarded an mbe
for his services to music they're a
calls for you to be stripped of your mbe
take it back i've never had that in my
possession except for a pitcher outside
buckingham palace
everything that gets done is for john
wolfe i ain't got an award
or a plaque or nothing and got nothing
in my yard to show john wolf's got the
mbe
i've never had the mbe it's framed in
his house now who was the mbe for
really don't think that i was sitting
there like oh where's my mbe i
need my obe i need my knighthood where's
my richard branson
no a spokesperson for wiley's former
manager
john wolfe says the rapper's mbe has
been framed
and is waiting for him to collect
wiley's twitter and instagram rants
have coincided with the black lives
matter movement
and among campaigners it has created a
discussion
i definitely think why these tweets are
dangerous i do think they could incite
violence
i know from firsthand like how
this stuff trickles down and stuff
online um crosses over to real life
because it's something i've suffered
and it's something that you know i tried
to show solidarity to jewish community
and i said
i'm really sorry for anyone triggered by
this and you know
it's beautiful it's really pitiful wiley
has now been permanently banned from
twitter
and other social media companies are
also considering
banning him forever his reputation has
been badly tarnished
and it's hard to see how he can recover
from this no phillips sky news